Sanuuu!
- You’re probably the best receiver
in the game in Throw Power.
- Thank you.
- But if you can throw it 70, then
your rating’s gonna keep goin’ up.
- What happens if he throws it 45?
- It could go down.
- There’s risk here.
♪♪♪
What’s going on, everybody?
Lefkoe here in Atlanta to
meet up with Mohamed Sanu,
the wide receiver with the
strongest arm in the NFL.
I wanna know how many quarterbacks
he can throw it farther than.
And just like a good State Farm agent,
Mohamed Sanu is just lookin’
to help us out.
See, I’m the sultan of segues,
and that’s called “branded content.”
It’s a little bit of a reach. I apologize.
But in all seriousness, State Farm is great.
Mohamed Sanu can throw far.
Let’s get it on.
♪♪♪
- Yooo!
Sanuuu!
- What’s up?
- What’s good, man?
- How you doin’?
- Dude, I’m so excited
we’re about to do this.
- Yeah, I’m pumped too.
- We get to show off
that arm cannon of yours.
- I’m pumped too, man.
- Lemme see.
- (Laughing)
- How much do you think we got in there?
75, 80?
- I don’t know, we gonna see.
- So we have 10 of the top quarterbacks in
the NFL laid out on the field with their
longest throws.
So we got Eli, Brady, Rodgers,
all the way up to Patrick Mahomes
at freakin’ 80 yards.
How many of these guys do you think
you can throw it farther than?
You’ve seen guys on the sideline—
- Maybe, like—maybe,
like, 50 percent of them.
40, 50 percent.
- OK.
If you reach Rodgers—
- Yeah.
- At 73?
Successful day.
- Right.
- I think you’re gonna pass Brady and Russ.
I mean, I think so too.
Maybe.
- That throw that I saw on Twitter—
- Uh-huh.
- In, like, the backyards?
- Oh, yeah.
- You were like, “How far is
that?!” How far was that, you think?
- It was pretty far.
It was, like, it was definitely 60-plus.
But I had to throw it over
the tree too, and a house.
- That’s crazy!
I also wanna see how fast you can throw it.
- Mhmm.
- We got a radar gun.
- Radar gun it.
- Have you ever done this before?
- Nah, I never done a radar gun.
- And I’m gonna try and catch one of your
passes, so please don’t break my fingers.
- OK.
I’ve done that before.
- You’ve broken someone’s finger?!
- Oh, definitely.
- Here we go, here we go.
Damn!
54.
You know that’s higher
than most quarterbacks?
Oh my God, and I caught—no!
Dammit!
I got so afraid, I wanted to talk to you.
What was that?
- 54.
- 54!
I’m catchin’ the next one.
Here we go.
Ohhh.
- 56.
- 56!
You were impressed by that catch though?
- Yeah, I was very impressed by the catch.
- I was nervous.
You played high school QB, right?
- Yeah.
- That’s probably when the
arm was the most fluid?
- Oh, definitely.
- How far are we throwin’ back then?
- Um, it was one day—it was a
little windy—I threw 84 and—
- 84!
- Yeah, the one day it wasn’t
windy, it was completely—
- What?! That’s, like, double me, bro.
I can imagine you weren’t too thrilled
with the Madden ratings that came out.
- No.
- Throw Power went from a 78 to a 72.
They made their ratings tougher—
- Yeah, they did.
- Which I understand.
- It’s cool.
- But a 72.
- Yeah, that’s very, very—
- I mean, that’s—Eli’s higher than that.
But now this is your chance to prove
everybody wrong, because we brought in a
Madden ratings adjustor.
♪♪♪
That’s the guy that you need to impress—
- He’s gonna adjust it?
- If you wanna get your numbers up.
- What’s up, guys?
- How you doin’,
nice to meet you.
- Hey, I’m Clint Oldenburg, Madden
Ratings Performance Adjustor.
- My man.
- We have you at a 72 Throw Power,
which is pretty good for a receiver.
You’re probably the best receiver
in the game in Throw Power.
- Thank you.
- Oooh.
- But if you can throw it past some of those
guys, then your rating’s gonna keep going up.
- What happens if he throws it, like, 45?
- Then the rating could go down.
- It could go down?
- It could go down.
There’s risk here.
- It’s time for Mohamed
Sanu to throw the ball deep.
- (Offscreen) 67.
67!
- All right, that’s,
that’s a good first throw.
- What are we thinkin’ right away?
- I mean, it—
- Did that—was that impressive to you?
- That was pretty impressive.
I mean, he has a quarterback background.
I think he can go a little further.
You know that you threw it past
Matt Ryan, your quarterback.
- Yeah, I knew that.
- He knew!
- All right, Throw 2. Here we go.
- That’s a spiral-and-a-half.
- He spun it.
I think that’s right at 70.
- Wow.
- It’s close.
- 69.
Nice.
- I have a little pressure to add to this.
- OK.
- If you can hit 70—which, you’re
really close, you’re a yard off—
- Mhmm.
- We’re gonna add a package of plays to
the Falcons playbook with you aligned at quarterback.
- OK.
Just for that, I’mma get that for
the fans, just cuz you said that.
- Oooh!
- All right.
- Cuz, you know, I know they been
askin’ for it, tweets all the time.
So just for that, I gotchu.
- I don’t wanna add too much pressure.
- There ain’t no such thing as pressure.
- A man of the people, Mohamed Sanu.
- Listen, ain’t no such thing as pressure.
- That extra yard—no such thing as pressure.
- I just make stuff happen.
(Grunting)
♪♪♪
- (Offscreen) 71.5!
- Yesss!
- For the fans, for the fans!
- Just for the fans.
- Get up, get up, get up!
- Just for the fans!
- Ahhh!
And he’s got a play in the
playbook as a quarterback!
- Just for the fans.
- Yes!
I was really nervous.
I thought 69 was gonna be your top.
- Nahhh.
- 71—
- Once I felt it here, I knew I could do it.
- Oooh, oooh.
- That’s pretty good.
- Sa-nuuu.
- I think we’re definitely in the 80s now.
You came in with a 72 Throw Power.
I think we’re definitely in the 80s.
- Definitely in the 80s?
- This is the best thing ever.
I feel like I’ve given a gift.
I didn’t even know I was doin’ all this.
- You givin’ a gift for all the fans.
- I can’t stop high-fivin’ you for no reason.
- You gave a gift to the Falcons fans.
- Yeah, Falcons fans get to use you.
- Yeah, we gave a gift to all the fans.
- (Brandon Gaudin) So barely
time to catch our breath.
Here’s 1st-and-10 just outside the red zone.
Lookin’ to throw, Mohamed Sanu!
Got his star receiver, it’s Jones!
- So we were hopin’ Mohamed Sanu
would outthrow 16 NFL quarterbacks.
At 71.5, he outthrew 28 starting
quarterbacks in the NFL.
We improved his Throw Power rating, and it
makes me think: NFL GMs, instead of looking
for a quarterback, maybe you
should look for a wide receiver.
Or at least pick him up in Madden.
What's up, guys?
It's Derrius Guice of the Washington Redskins.
Make sure you subscribe to Bleacher Report
to catch more episodes from
Ditch the Playbook with Lefkoe.
Sadly.
[Laughing]
- [Offscreen] That was great.